انتشرت في الاونه الاخيره توقعات لعلماء
ومتخصصين في الزلازل بحدوث هزات ارضيه في
بعض دول الشرق الاوسط وتحديدا منطقه
الخليج تبقى تلك التوقعات في نظر البعض
مجرد تكهنات لا يمكن حدوثها في ظل الكثير
من الدراسات والابحاث التي تجري في علم
الزلازل سعود الخلف مع تفاصيل
رغم تنوع الدراسات التي تجريها المراكز
البحثيه بشان الكوارث الطبيعيه التي تشهد
الكره الارضيه لا تزال الزلازل هاجسا
مؤرقا للعديد من الدول في العالم الامر
الذي دعا متخصصين في المنطقه العربيه الى
اجراء المزيد من البحوث والدراسات ليس من
المعقول ان تكون هناك جهات او قوه لتحريك
هذه
البلاطه او تسبب في الزلازل انما هي قد
يكون هناك اجتهادات علميه لكن في الواقع
كجيولوجيا كدراسه الزلازل وبراكين لا يمكن
لاحد ان يتحكم في حركه صخور
لالاف الكيلومترات
وبساماكه عشرات الالاف من امتار ان تحركها
اي قوه كانت الا قوه الله سبحانه وتعالى
منطقه البحر الاحمر كانت نقطه الاختلاف
الذي دار بين المتخصصين منذ كارثه الزلازل
التي ضربت مناطق في تركيا وسوريا خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه حيث ذهب البعض الى ان
البحر الاحمر معرض لخطر الزلازل التي قد
تضرب بعض المدن المجاوره بحر احمر في
زلازل لكن تاثير علينا محدود لكن نتيجه
لشده الحراره
الموجوده في قاع وسط قاع البحر
فانها تعمل على اضمحلال الموجات الصادره
من الزلازل في وسط البحر الاحمر المدن
السعوديه على الرغم من تسجيل هزات ارضيه
محدوده خلال العقود الماضيه الا ان مراكز
الابحاث والتاريخ الزلزالي تؤكد بعد دول
الخليج عن انشطه الزلازل نحمد الله انا
لدي نا مساحه جيولوجيه وان هناك محطات
كثيره للرسل الزلزالي تتم متابعه جميع
الهزات مهما كانت صغيره لا يشعر بها
الانسان الى الزلازل الكبيره وبالتالي
تنتشر المحطات
والرصد الزلزالي موجود ونحن باذن الله
جزيره العرب بشكل عام والمملكه بشكل خاص
تقع ضمن الجزء المستقر من البلاط العربيه
يرى متخصصون ضروره التجديد خلال الفتره
المقبله على تطبيق المعايير المضاده
للزلازل في المباني وتصميمها بمواصفات
متوافقه وامنه من الهزات الارضيه اضافه
الى نشر الثقافه العامه بين الشعوب من جده
سعود الخلف العربيه
من جده ينضم الينا رئيس اللجنه الاستشاريه
للزلازل ومدير مركز الازمات والكوارث هيت
المساحه الجيولوجيه السعوديه الدكتور هاني
زهران دكتور هاني حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض
هل البحر الاحمر فعلا معرض لخطر الزلزال
في البدايه اشكر قناه العربيه على استضافه
حياه الى اللقاء
وبالنسبه للبحر الاحمر حقيقه الاغلب
الزلازل اللي تقع في البحر الاحمر هي
زلازل ضعيفه الى متوسطه يعني
حتى الزلازل اللي سايره في خلال الخمسين
سنه من الستينات الى الان على سبيل المثال
الزلزال اللي اتكلم فيه البعض انه عام 67
بالقرب من
جنوب غرب جده هذا زلزال كان قوته 5.7 وليس
قوه فوق السته يعني كل الزلازل اللي بتكون
في البحر الاحمر هي
زلازل من ضعيفه الى متوسطه ايش السبب
خلينا نتكلم اول حاجه عن حدود الصفيحه
العربيه وهذه اللي توضح الامور بشكل جيد
الصفيحه العربيه واللي هي تضم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
وايضا
في اليمن دول الخليج وفي الشمال ايضا
العراق وسوريا والاردن الصفيحه العربيه
يحدها من الغرب البحر الاحمر وهذا طبعا
البحر الاحمر هو صدع انفتاحي لكن هذه
الصفيحه يا دكتور
هذه الصفيحه يعني جزء منها تعرض
للزلزال الزلزال الاخير الزلزال تركيا
وسوريا هو جزء من الصفيحه العربيه ايضا
تاثر في في شمال غرب سوريا فالسؤال الان
هل يمكن ان يكون مثلا هناك
تداعيات او صدع معين حدث في هذه الصفيحه
او خلل ايضا حدث ممكن ان يؤثر على مناطق
ومساحه جغرافيه اوسع او ابعد من هذه
النقطه في ذات الصفيحه العربيه التي نقع
عليها ومن ضمنها البحر الاحمر
بالتاكيد لا لانه الزلازل داخل المملكه ما
في صدوع رئيسيه تكتونيه تمر داخل الصفيحه
العربيه
واغلب الزلازل اللي بتقع في الصفيحه
العربيه بتقع على حدود الصفيحه العربيه
يعني على سبيل المثال الجزء اللي هو
الشمالي الغربي من الصفيحه العربيه
وبنتكلم عن خليج العقبه وامتداده اللي هو
صدع البحر الميت يمتد نعم يمتد في الاردن
وسوريا
والى الى الشمال ليلتقي بصدع شرق الاناضول
هذا الصدع يعني ما بيصير فيه زلازل غير
على فترات متباعده تقريبا تاريخيا كل 500
سنه بيصير زلزال في هذا السطح وهذا اللي
بيمرعب بالمنطقه العربيه كامله بعيده عن
انشطه الزلازل
لا ما هي بعيده طبعا بيصير في هذه الازال
على زلازل على سبيل المثال صار اخر زلزال
في خليج العقبه عام 95
وبالنسبه الى الزلازل اللي في البحر
الاحمر هذه زلازل غير مخيفه نهائيا ولا
تؤثر على
المدن الساحليه في المملكه لانها لما تكلم
حتى بعد الصدع اللي يشق منتصف البحر
الاحمر
بعيد عرض البحر الاحمر من 200 الى 300
كيلو تلاقي منتصفه عالميه وخمسين كيلو
من الشمال الى الجنوب وكل الزلازل اللي
بتقع فيه زلازل من ضعيفه الى متوسطه
وبيصرنها ايضا تهوين الموجات الزلزاليه
بتعدي على طبقات بيصير لها او تهين الى ان
تصل الى المدن الساحليه على المطله على
البحر الاحمر وهذه ما كانت مؤثره نهائيا
وحتى الزلازل اللي سايره سابقا ما تعدت من
عام 67 او من الس الى الان ما تعدت السته
يعني ما تعدت دكتور هاني يعني يعني هل هل
هل تطمئن
سكان
الشرق الاوسط الخليج ايضا تحديدا بانهم
بعيدين تماما عن خطر اي زلازل مشابهه الله
يكفينا يعني نفس
الزلازل اللي حدثت يعني في تركيا في سوريا
لانه في كثير شائعات وكثير حديث عن هذا
الموضوع وانشطه زلزاليه في اكثر من منطقه
في العالم فبالتالي الخوف او الخشيه موجود
وبالنسبه لدول الخليج دول الخليج طبعا
كلها بتقع في بعيده عنها اقرب صدع لها
اللي هو صدع زاجروس وتوروس اللي هو من
ناحيه ايران وهذا ما ياثر على دول الخليج
طبعا تاثيره كل شعور وتاثير ضعيف ما هو
مدمر ولا هو ياسر حتى لو سار زلزال بقوه
سبعه هناك ما ياثر على دول الخليج بعيده
كمسافه وايضا ارتداديه
وحتى الهزات الارتداديه دائما بتكون اضعف
من الزلازل الرئيسيه بتصير ولكن يعني لما
تجي تطالع ايضا حتى اللي هو
على سبيل المثال اللي هو صدع الشركه
الاناضول اللي في في تركيا هذا الصدع هو
عباره عن شمال سوريا وجنوب تركيا يعني جزء
جنوبي من تركيا هذا
الاخيره نعم بالضبط بين الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه الصفيحه
وصدع انزلاقي هذا اللي صار فيه زلزال لو
جينا احنا رجعنا للصدع اللي هو شماله شضع
صدع شمال الاناضول على سبيل المثال هذا
صار في الزلازل يعني من عام تسعه وتلاتين
من عام 1939 وبعد كذا صار زلزال اللي بعده
يليه في المكان مكانيا وزمانيا عام 42 و43
وفي الخمسينات وفي 99 كل الزلازل السابقه
اللي سايره في تركيا سايره على شمال
الاناضول وكانت التوقعات كلها الزلازل في
تركيا على هذا الصدع وتؤثر على على سبيل
المثال على اسطنبول والمناطق هذه
الخبراء والمتابعين
والدراسات ومتابعي التاريخ بانه لم يكن
يمكن مفاجاه لكن التوقيت كان مفاجئ والحجم
ايضا كذلك المساحه الجغرافيه شكرا جزيلا
لك من جده رئيس اللجنه الاستشاريه للزلازم
مدير مركز الازمات الكوارث في هيئه
المساحه الجيولوجيه السعوديه الدكتور هاني
زهران شكرا يا دكتور